so one of the main purposes of
accounting for anything of making these
accounting statements in the first place
is so that you can reflect what's going
on in the business and that might be for
investors to see how a business is doing
or it might be for the managers of a
business so that they can see where the
business is doing well or where it's not
doing well or maybe how resources should
be allocated so let's see which of these
two methods of accounting the cash
method or the accrual method give a
better indication of what's actually
going on in the business and the way I
did it in the first two videos for each
month this first column right over here
this is the cash basis of accounting and
this right here is the accrual so the
second column is the accrual let's just
look at the income statement we're
assuming a very simple world where
there's no taxes we have no debt we have
no interest things like that we just
literally have revenue some expenses
associated with that revenue and just a
simple profit and we'll make it more
complicated in the future so this right
here you could view as our income
statement this is our income statement
for month one on a cash basis this is
our income statement on month one on an
accrual basis now when you look at the
cash basis in month one and when you
look at the cat either basis on month
one it gives you the same thing so
that's not so interesting but let's go
to month two and the cash basis of
accounting it looks like you just lost
$200 to an outsider who didn't know the
details of what's actually going on the
business they think something shady is
going on or it's a money losing business
why would I want to invest in this
they're losing $200 a month just looking
at this month alone but when you go look
at the accrual basis it better reflects
it look you actually did some catering
in fact you did a pretty large catering
event that month in fact that's why you
had so many expenses and if you if you
recognize the revenue for the service
that you actually did that month that
$400 which we did in the accrual basis
then you can actually so look I perform
services that will earn me $200 assuming
that the customer is going to be good
for their money and instead of putting
that $400 in cash because you didn't get
the cash you can't do that we said look
the customer owes us $400 but that's
still an asset an asset is anything that
someone owes you some future benefit so
the customer is going to
give you cash in the future cash is an
asset because you can use that to go buy
stuff to get other people to do stuff
for you to get some future benefits so
both cash and accounts receivables are
assets and so in months do I think it's
fair that accrual method is giving us a
better indication of what actually
happened let's go to month 3 on the cash
basis and we look at the example we
actually did nothing in month 3 you
could have gone on a vacation in month 3
there was no actual catering done but on
the cash basis it looks like this was
your best month of catering ever because
you actually got $600 inflow in cash and
you didn't have to spend any expenses
because you didn't do any accounting but
when you do the accrual basis it
actually reflected what happened you had
no revenue and no expenses associated
with that revenue so once again to an
outsider they'd see a month 3 maybe you
took a break maybe you took a vacation
or that was just a slow time in your
business and you don't recognize the
revenue from this $200 in advance
because you didn't do anything to get it
instead you said look I got this $200
it's a cash advance you could have even
called this a cash advance from
customers but I'm not recognizing this
in revenue in the month that I got it
I'm waiting until I actually perform the
service so I'm deferring the revenue and
so you defer to month 4 when you
actually perform the service the hundred
dollars expenses are associated with
that $200 and so it makes sense that you
had a hundred dollars in profit once
again in month four you did work
you should have profit on the cash basis
it looks like you lost money again so
hopefully this gives you a little bit of
an idea of why accrual gives a better
picture of what's happening in a
business in the next video I'll try to
reconcile the the what the accrual
income statement is telling us and the
actual cash because right now it might
look a little mysterious